there's something missing in our
understanding of intelligence
intelligence isn't just training uh the
way the neural network is conceived
right now is gray and it's lovely and
it'll be better and we'll argue forever
but you want to know wouldn't it be
great if I said look I know how to
invent an architecture and I can give it
a soul and what I mean by a soul
is some I know for real that there is
internal reference
as soon as like not fake internal
reference and if we could generate that
mechanism for internal reference that's
why our goal Direction that's why you
have to we can do that get that goal
Direction you would love that robot more
than the one that's just made to look
like it does because you'll have more
fun with it because you better generate
certain other problems get more novelty
hell you'll be able to fall in love with
that robot for real but not the one
that's Faking It
what about fake it till you make it well
I think a lot of people fall in love
with with
um with fake humans it's not it's nice
to it's nice to fall in love with
something that's full of novelty yes I I
you know I can imagine all kinds of
robots that I would want to have a close
relationship with and I don't mean like
sexual I mean like intimacy because but
I just don't think that um
novelty generation is such a special
okay there's like mathematical novelty
or something like that and then there's
just humans being surprised and I think
we're easily surprised that's fine but
that's that but you don't think that's a
good day I'm happy to be surprised
um
but not globally surprised because
someone else but I really want I was why
I'm a scientist I really want to be
the first to be surprised about
something and the first thing in the
first in the universe have created that
novelty and to know for sure that that
novelty has never occurred anywhere else
that's a real Buzz right that's a way to
really know that I I you have to have a
really big look up team right yeah
you're never going to know for sure
right that's that's one of the hard
things about being
and science is searching for this type
of novelty maybe that's why mathematics
mathematicians love
Discovery but actually they are creating
and then when they create a new
um mathematical structure that they can
then they you can you can write code to
work out whether there's whether that
structure exists before that that's
almost why I would love to have been a
mathematician from that regard to invent
new math that really I know pretty much
for sure does not exist does not exist
anywhere else in the universe because so
contingent right but this gets into like
you are you said a few times but I still
really don't understand how you actually
plan to do this to build an experiment
that detects how the universe is
generating novelty or that time is the
mechanism so the the problem that we all
have which I think is what Lex is
pushing against is if I build the
experiment
you don't know what you put into it so
you don't know it like if you unless you
can quantify everything you put in all
of your agency all the boundary
conditions you don't know if you somehow
biased it in some way so is the novelty
actually intrinsic to that experiment or
to that robot or is it something you
gave it but you didn't realize it's
gonna be it's gonna asymptote towards
that right you're never going to know
for sure but you can start to take out
you know you can use good Bayesian
approaches and just keep updating and
updating and updating until you point
until 11 episodes on how much novelty
generation it could be yeah got it
so the ability generating novelty is
correlated with high assembly index with
assembly index yeah and yeah
because the space
bigger
so
um that's the key this could be a good
uh so we're running joke of like why Lex
is single this could be a good part for
uh so you so what you're looking for in
a robot partner is ability to generate
novelty
foreign
you would say it's a good definition of
intelligence too
boys novelty a um
a fuzzy concept
is creativity better
yeah I mean that's that's all pretty
fuzzy it's kind of the same maybe that's
why aliens haven't come yet is because
we're not creating enough novelty like
there's this some kind of a hierarchy of
novelty in the universe well I think
novelty is like things surprise you
right so it's a very passive thing but I
guess I would remember by saying
creativity is I think it's much more
active like you think there's like a
mechanism of like the things that exist
are generating the creativity novelty
seems to be there's some spontaneous
production it has it's completely
decoupled from the things that exist no
I I understand
creativity is the mechanism and Novelty
is the observable yeah novelty could
just be surprised your model of the
world was broken and and not necessarily
in a positive way that's the prize so
there's three things now let's go back
that's cool right let's go you've got
surprise which is basically I'm I don't
I mean I'm surprised all the time
because I don't read very much I'm
pretty dumb I was like oh wow I often
used to invent new scientific you know
ideas and I was really surprised by that
and then when looking literature
properly and it's there so surprise
that's to the extent that you don't have
full information
creativity the act of pushing
on that um kind of on the causals
structure and Novelty which is measuring
that degree right so and I think that's
pretty well defined in that regard so
you want your robot I mean in the and in
the end that's why actually the way the
internet and the printing press share
some um I actually think creativity has
dropped a bit since it created since the
internet because everyone's just just
you know just regurgitating stuff but of
course now it's beginning to accelerate
again because everyone's using this tool
to be creative and boom is exploding
now I think that's what happens when you
create these new technologies that's
really that's really helpful there's a
difference between novelty and surprise
okay I was I think I was thinking about
surprise if you give me a toy that
surprises me for a bit I'd be great
robot surprises me yeah experiment that
surprises you yeah I mean that's why I
love doing experiments because I'm I
can't it's still exciting yeah surprise
is exciting yep
even negative surprise like some people
love drama in relationships like
it's like why the hell what why'd you do
this that could be exciting I could
imagine companies selling updates to
their their companion robots are just
basically generate negative surprise
just to just spice things up a bit yeah
it's the push and pull that's that's one
of the components of love as you said
love is a complicated thing